hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game that was played today in the
protest league between peruvian
grandmaster jorge quarry and ali reza
Fallujah and I was gonna show you a
different game but then I saw this one
and I said it and this one but I will
show you the game that I was gonna show
you tomorrow it's again between Fabiana
Quran and ding leerin as a way of
getting warmed up for the candidates but
that's gonna have to wait for tomorrow
because this is just a beauty so like I
said a pro chess league rapid game let's
check it out
Corey with the white pieces opens with
d4 we have Knight to f6 Knight to f3
we have d5 c4 and e6 of course we go
into the Queen's Gambit a client III
Bishop to e7 and the Knight to c3
so all standard stuff we have castles a
trade in the center captures captures
and Bishop to d3 we have c6
strengthening the center and the now h3
taking away the g4 squares from
ferocious pieces and rook to e8 now we
have Queen to c2 it's an acquaintance c2
the new move there are a few games there
where castles was played here but Queen
to c2 a new move by Corey so already as
of move 9 we have a completely new game
with Bishop to d6 by Fallujah before
deciding where to start pushing
immediately maybe or - maybe consolidate
but first Bishop to d6 also this now
allows the black rook to be included in
the fight for the e4 square we have
Bishop to b2 now may be deciding to
Castle queenside and Knight B to d7 with
g4 saying that ok I'm more of a more
interested in attacking the king said
than actually castling kingside myself
Queen to e7 piling up on the e-file as
Corey scheme is still in the center of
the board and now Corey castles Queen
side we have Knight to e4 still fallujah
waits with with the pushing of the pawns
and here the F to pawn is under attack
so not interested in capturing he
decides to keep detention with rook F to
D 1 we have Knights the f8 by future
preparing to bring the knight over 2 G 6
and now kink the b1
not only a prophylactic move making the
room getting the King to a safer Square
but also freeing up the C 1 square for
the bishop if needed Knight to g6 and
the now comes the shove the c1 so not
avoiding any unnecessary trades with
bishop to be formed by Fallujah now
preparing the capture and the mess up
our chorus pawn structure here but
Knight to e2 not again not making it
easy for Fallujah to trade pieces Bishop
to d7 again Fallujah waits with the
pushing of the points on the Queen side
and now Knight to f4 preparing to get
rid of the knight here and also create
some weaknesses on the King side and
also if future captures then he doesn't
mess up White's pawn structure but white
gets an excellent
efile outpost for his knight which which
happens anyway so it doesn't really
matter
Fallujah looked the c8 continues
developing pieces and now we have Knight
captures in g 6h captures and now Knight
to e5 finally the knight gets there and
it's gonna be very hard to get it away
from there as it's on a it's on a very
nice square f6 is no longer possible as
the g6 pawn is weak so if you want to
get it away from there you tur have to
waste a lot of moves with the night but
your knight is on an excellent square as
well or you can play someone like rush
up here and then try and trade it off
but that this is a valid valuable
attacking piece so c5 as you know
Corey's coming on the Kings side so it
doesn't make sense the strike in the
center and open some files here
especially since the rook and queen
occupy the same file Queen e2 getting
out of the way and now c4 basically
forcing a trade only four characters
captures and now f4 Corey starts his
attack on the Kings side but fallujah
not impressed he goes c3 and Corey now
not impressed twist with ferocious move
f5 so really a wonderful game where each
player just tends to his own own own
side of the board and now before doing
any captures here bishop to a4 he wants
to reinforce the C 2 square so when the
capture occurs you can do this very nice
rook lift with rook to c2 but Corey
again unimpressed just F captures and g6
now threatening to
to here with check when material and win
the game so future has to react he plays
f6 although even even capturing was
possible because if Luke to f7 then
Queen to b6 d6 is an excellent square
for the Queen and after you try and do
something let's say rook captures and b7
now now you can go captures captures and
roof to c2 and it's all of a sudden
fallujah who is attacking but he decided
to go for f6 instead which kicks away
the night from e5 that's true but it
allows this point to be incredibly
strong and at some point in g5 will be
played Queen is coming to h5 and future
could have some problems on the Kings
side or not we'll see what happens
so Corey immediately was for g5 freeze
the h5 square for his queen and here we
have C captures and be too daring whites
to go for Queen to h5 but before that he
decides that it's important to capture
on b2 so Bishop captures on b2 and now
what do you play here there's actually
only one good move for future here so
pause the video and try to find it while
I give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations as it's really not an
easy move to decide upon and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's Bishop to e3 Bishop to a3 pretty
much the only move that stops the Queen
h5 idea because now if you go here now
the problem is you have Bishop the c2
trick and now wherever the King goes
only then do you capture and b2 with
check so you don't give y the
opportunity to deliver the check on h7
so let's taking it one captures captures
and now Queen before a lands with check
if if you move to a 1 then just Queen c3
is made so came to C 1 but now you go in
in front of the rook so Bishop to a4
with check and now the King has no
squares you have to block with something
doesn't really matter where you go rook
captures and c6 will be made so
basically after Bishop to a3 Queen h5 is
no longer an option you have to go
something like characters characters
Knight g4 and then continue the game
Bishop c2 with check and after this the
game continues
so here it's extremely complicated white
would have to go capture
and then after captures captures on a
three attacks the Queen but it's just a
beautiful line so so I will show it
captures here now you capture on f6 with
check King h8 and now g7 with check
captures captures with check King h8 and
now your capture here and now it's two
rooks and a knight against a queen but
with the White King being so wide in the
open he's gonna have a lot of problems
getting out of all the check so here we
would most likely see a draw by
perpetual so like I said after this
captures Bishop to a3 was the strongest
move for Fallujah but instead he rushed
in with rook to c2 which which seems
seems overwhelming for white but Corey
still does the only thing he can Queen
h5 which was the plan all along so that
makes it all that much easier and now
the problem is Queen h7 is coming if you
allow that King f8 Queen each it is made
and if you try giving your King some
squares to run away to the Queen side
still not gonna happen because of Queen
h7 checking f8 and now this rook
captures on f6 check you capture and now
of course check King has the move and
Queen captures on f6 will be made so
there's that
so instead of trying to run away or
trying to defend fallujah starts a king
hunt of his own rook captures and b2
with check so what happens here
King captures and then now Bishop the c3
check future gives up a bishop here it's
important to also check out Bishop to e3
check because well let's say King a1
what do you do now go shabby to check
problem is white will not capture and
allow Queen before check white which is
gonna go King here and now if you give
white just one move let's say Queen
before now okay if you if you get a move
in you win but you don't Queen a trade
the Queen 87 checking f8 and now Queen
88 to check King has to run away Queen
captures here with check King to d8
captures with check you go here check
and now you go here and now finally
Knight to d7 which are now it doesn't
matter if you capture the knight or try
and run away White's next move is the
same if captures Queen to c5 and now you
force a queen trade
and there's not much black can do to
continually attacked characters captures
and after you get your Bishop to safety
let's say h4 ended up connected points
will do the job will do the job done
so after King captures here Bishop to e3
Fallujah decides it's not working
decides for Bishop to c3 check instead
Corey captures and now rook the c8 with
check but again we have to check Queen
a3 check will will it be enough or the
King escapes King D - Queen B - check
King to e1 and now Queen c1 check this
is the problem you cannot keep an eye on
the f2 square while checking the White
King so he uses the F 2 squared to
escape King the future King g3 captures
King goes back and after another capture
you finally get a move in rook F 2 and
now black has to make us make a move and
allow Queen h7 or you trade here but
it's not gonna be it's not gonna do
anything for you since well you are down
a whole rook and of course white is
completely winning so instead a future
goes looked the c8 with check we have
Knight to c4 blocking and now again rook
captures and c4 check by Fallujah but
again it's important to check if Queen
to a3 check is possible because the
knight is pinned you cannot capture with
the night so let's see if this works
King D - now rope captors and c4 because
you don't really have a better move you
could you could capture here but still
King to a1 and again you have the same
problem you cannot keep the king keep
the control of DF 2 Square and check the
King so here if you play rook captures
then it's just Queen h7 check King f8
and now this beautiful rope captures on
f6 check impossible to capture because
of Queen f7 will now be made there's a
pawn on g6 as you all know King is 7 but
now just captures King to d8 and now
let's say Queen g7 check Buster blocks
and you pick up the rook and again
whites is up to much material and
there's no way to continue the game for
black so after Knight c4 quinta a3
doesn't work for future so firoozeh
plays rook captures on c4 we have King
captures and now b5 with check this is
this is one hell of a king hunt and
luckily for Corey he does have the seat
if he goes here then then he runs into
queen bee seven check so king c3 now
queen III check King to b2 and Quinta d3
with check with King Teti one and now
Queen captures on e3 with check but now
you don't have the d1 square the bishop
covers that but luckily you can bring
your queen at the back to help out with
the defense Queen to g3 check by future
King to d2 now not even not even
blocking so King D to Queen to g5 with
check Quinta III and now Queen to d5
trying to deliver some more checks from
here but Cory says nope rook the c1 and
okay Fallujah played Quinta a2 with
check but now Corey just played King
Teti 1 and it was in this position that
all there is a Fallujah resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here he's simply too much down too much
material and there is no way to continue
the attack so whatever happens the the Y
doesn't really have all that much to
worry about he he can just play some
like Quinta D to start pushing his
passport I'll get his auto rook into the
game and there's no way to continue this
game so really really an amazing game by
both of them and as you know the
greatest games are played by not won by
but but but by two players so both of
them have to give their contribution for
such a game to exist and in this game
two of them did to give their
contribution so really amazing stuff
brilliant attacking game Fallujah was
better for for a long time in the
beginning but then after rushing that
rook to see to move allowing Queen to h5
then it was just all Corey so really
impressive stuff I I do hope you enjoyed
it and tell the truth how many of you
thought a future was gonna win this game
when he started the King hunt when I was
watching a game I thought he was
definitely gonna finish it but you know
Corey put back the attack and he came up
he came out on top so a really
impressive stuff like I said tomorrow we
continue with the Murphy saga and we're
gonna check up on that game I mentioned
between Dean and Fabi so I do hope you
enjoyed that as well I would like to
thank Morten restore Jonathan Owen
Austin Begum impacts srl and Elias novel
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot to really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Morphy
saga a continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and of course
whatever else happens in the chess world
the candidates tournament starts in
three days or if it's postponed maybe it
doesn't but then what are you gonna do
with a meal does that a job will go back
in or does in VL states is gonna be a
whole mess but that's what jess is all
about sure thank you I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your
weekend